finden wir schon bald sehr bald
außerirdisches leben der start des
leistungsfähigsten weltraum teleskop das
es je gab mit einer europäischen
ariane-5-rakete steht bevor das james
webb weltraumteleskop hebt am 24
dezember um 13 20 mitteleuropäischer
zeit vom europäischen weltraum hafen in
französisch guyana ab schon nach 200
stunden beobachtungszeit also nach
wenigen tagen einsatzfähig im weltraum
könnte der hubble nachfolger dann
bereits außerirdisches leben gefunden
haben doch wird das teleskop den staat
unbeschadet überstehen diese frage hat
den staat bisher erheblich für zur
stützung science news gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science windows
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen was lange währt wird
endlich gut laut den neuen plänen der
nasa esa und der kanadischen
raumfahrt-agentur csc wird das
weltraumteleskop james webb an
heiligabend ins all starten können
ursprünglich war der 18 12 2021 geplant
daraus wurde dann zunächst der 22 12 und
nun heißt es dass das mega weltraum
teleskop wohl erst an heiligabend am
24.12 starten kann laut nasa und
arianespace sind es technische probleme
die zu den verzögerungen führen dennoch
mindern diese nicht die riesigen
erwartungen die auf den james webb
teleskop an eine aktuelle studie macht
jetzt sogar noch mehr hoffnung laut der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
könnte der hubble nachfolger bereits
nach relativ kurzen beobachtungszeiten
signaturen von möglichem leben erfassen
bereits nach 200 beobachtungs stunden
könnte es soweit sein und das james webb
teleskop könnte auch planeten des
systems tapies 1 spuren von
außerirdischem leben gefunden haben wie
kommen die forscherinnen und forscher
darauf und wie groß sind die chancen
wirklich die antworten auf all diese
fragen und noch viele weitere spannende
infos zum start das habe nachfolgers
gibt es jetzt hier bei klicks als im
flugzeug das internationale
forschungsteam hat vor allem dem
planeten tab ist 1 ins visier genommen
es handelt sich um einen exoplaneten der
in dem werk stand ist eins in der
habitablen zone umkreist er befindet
sich etwa 40 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt und verfügt über sieben
planeten von denen sich schätzungen
zufolge mindestens zwei bis vier in der
habitablen zone befehlen aussichtsreiche
kandidatin bei unserer suche nach
außerirdischen leben also denn in der
habitablen zone wird mit flüssigem
wasser gerechnet in der aktuellen studie
ging es den fachleuten vor allem um tab
ist ein erdähnliche planet wenn er etwas
kleiner und leichter ist als unser
heimatplanet zudem weist er eine
geringere dichte auf und es herrscht
eine sogenannte gleichgewichts
temperatur von minus 22 grad celsius die
fachwelt ist sich ziemlich sicher dass
trabis 1e eine ozean welt sein könnte
aufgespürt wurde er mit der hilfe des
spitzer weltraumteleskops und zwar über
die sogenannten transitmethode alle
sieben planeten des tablett 1 system zum
kreisen ins werk stand in einer
sogenannten gebundenen rotation das
bedeutet dass eine seite nie und die
andere seite immer vom stern beschienen
wird auf der einen seite herrscht also
ein immerwährender tag und auf der
anderen seite immer werden danach
zwischen diesen warmen und kalten
temperaturen liegt eine ringförmige zone
in der mittlere temperaturen
vorherrschen die transitmethode also
basiert darauf dass solche planeten
regelmäßig von der stern scheibe vorbei
ziehen und dadurch die stern strahlung
abnehmen wichtig hierbei das ganze ist
gemeint aus der perspektive der erde
sobald sich also ein exot planet von uns
aus gesehen vor seiner sonne schiebt
erreicht uns periodisch etwas weniger
licht nur durch fachleute auf seine
existenz schließen können mit hilfe
dieser sogenannten transitmethode werden
fast täglich mehr und mehr exoplaneten
aufgespürt laut der us weltraumagentur
nasa sind es mittlerweile nach dem
aktuellen stand ende dezember 2021
insgesamt knapp 5000 bestätigt der
exoplaneten und fast 8000 mögliche
kandidaten für die forschung sind solche
dran sind planeten ganz besonders
spannend objekte denn solch ein transit
ermöglicht es den fachleuten die bahn
lage die größe und die atmosphäre des
planeten genauer zu bestimmen durch
diese parameter kann dann letztendlich
auch in das innere des planeten geschaut
werden da diese parameter einiges über
den aufbau des planeten verraten so
wollen astronomie teams lang für sich
auch endlich verstehen nach welchen
regeln sich planetensysteme b die große
hoffnung der fachwelt ruth einzig und
alleine auf dem james webb teleskop denn
das kann viel mehr als seine vorgänger
denn mit seiner hilfe soll schon bald
nicht nur die potenzielle lebens
freundlichkeit eines planeten bewertet
werden im besten fall könnte sogar dabei
helfen sogenannte biomarker nachzuweisen
denn nur das james webb weltraumteleskop
kann das überhaupt gemeint sind damit
chemische moleküle die als ergebnis
biologischer prozesse bekannt sind
zumindest auf der erde eine aktuelle
studie an der auch der deutsche max
planck wissenschaftler thomas
mega-events beteiligter stützt die
hoffnung dass mit dem hubble nachfolger
schon nach relativ kurzen
beobachtungszeiten signaturen möglichen
lebens auf einem der planeten des
systems trappisten 1 schon nach 200
beobachtungs stunden gefunden werden
könnten das forschungsteam hat in seiner
studie die atmosphäre des planeten trapp
ist als in verschiedenen zuständen
modelliert dann analysierten die
forschenden wie viele dran setzt des
planeten vor der sonnenscheibe seines
sterns das neue weltraumteleskop
beobachten müsste um belastbare aussagen
zu treffen inhaltlich geht es hierbei um
das vorhandensein von zwei chemischen
verbindungen die auch als klassische
lebens zutaten bezeichnet werden methan
ch4 und kohlenstoffdioxid co2
dazu heißt es in der aktuellen studie
sollte trapp ist eine atmosphärische
zusammensetzung ähnlich jener der erde
des teams aufweisen so könnten
eindeutige nachweise von ch4 und co2
bereits nach fünf bis zehn beobachteten
ansitz erbracht werden selbst wenn die
rahmenbedingungen wie die druck und
bewölkung verhältnisse eher ungünstig
ausfallen würden wären entsprechende
nachweise schon bei bis zu 30 transits
möglich im klartext heißt das dass eine
exklusive beobachtungszeit von maximal
200 stunden notwendig sein wird bereits
dann kann die fachwelt also
möglicherweise mit der hilfe des james
webb teleskops eine entscheidende frage
bei der suche nach außerirdischem leben
beantworten sind entsprechende biomarker
in der trab ist als atmosphäre vorhanden
oder nicht doch erste ergebnisse werden
noch nicht im januar vorliegen zuerst
hat das weltraumteleskop
eine lange reise vor sich sein zieht
liegt in 1,5 millionen kilometer
entfernung außerhalb der erdumlaufbahn
fachleute sprechen vom 2 punkt der erde
l2 ein ziemlich guter einsatzort für
teleskope da diese hier von der
strahlung der sonne besser abgeschirmt
sind als auf einer erdumlaufbahn
er liegt nämlich also l2 hinter der
umlaufbahn des mondes im erdschatten
objekte sind hier keinen gravitations
kräften ausgesetzt und können somit ohne
antrieb die sonne umkreisen hier ist das
james webb teleskop nicht das erste
menschengemachte objekt auch das
herrsche und das plank weltraumteleskop
theresa waren hier schon am start
einziges problem sobald das james webb
teleskop einmal in der umlaufbahn l2
positioniert ist kann es auch nicht mehr
repariert werden beim hubble
weltraumteleskop ist das anders gewesen
es befindet sich in einer erdumlaufbahn
und wurde immer mal wieder angepasst
gewartet und repariert zumindest solange
space shuttles in den weltraum fliegen
konnten einen monat etwa sollte die
reisezeit des teleskops dauern bis es
dann im lz ankommt weitere zwei bis drei
monate wird es dann brauchen bis die
instrumente alle eingeschaltet werden um
bis zu sechs monate später wird ihre
funktionsweise getestet worden sein
heißt also wenn alles nach plan läuft
könnten die wissenschaftlichen
beobachtungen im sommer 2022 beginnen
und dafür stehen wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler bereits jetzt
schlange kein wunder denn das
riesenteleskop wurde ja unter anderem
mehr speziell dafür entwickelt
außerirdisches leben zu suchen anders
als das hubble teleskop das mit
sichtbarem namen ultravioletten und nahe
infraroten spektrum sucht ist das james
webb weltraumteleskop ein supertalent im
infraroten bereich so kann es
beispielsweise die atmosphäre von
exoplaneten analysiert die wiederum
hinweise auf planet ares leben gibt die
satelliten und teleskopen die wir
derzeit zur verfügung haben sind dafür
einfach nicht leistungsstarken aber
nicht nur dass fachleute erwarten
unglaubliche aufnahmen und erkenntnisse
zu sterne und planetensysteme und
zuletzt könnte das riesenteleskop auch
dazu beitragen endlich dem mysteriösen
rätsel um die dunkle materie auf die
spur zu kommen gekostet hat der bau des
teleskops rund 10 milliarden us dollar
sein haus spiegel hat einen durchmesser
von 6 metern und ist mit gold bedampft
dieser besteht aus 18 wabenförmigen
segmenten muss zusammengefaltet werden
um in die ariane-5-trägerrakete zu
passen dazu sagt die astronomen john
wright die das teleskop mit konstruiert
und entwickelt hat die rationale seite
von mir sagt das alles schon viele male
getestet wurde ich habe alle analysen
gesehen da gibt es wirklich nichts
worüber man sich sorgen machen müsste
aber die weniger rationale seite von mir
sagt oh mein gott sie werden dieses
teleskop auf eine rakete setzen und sie
in stücke schütteln denn das war eines
der großen probleme das den start des
teleskops erheblich verzögert hatte bei
rüttelt es hatten sich schrauben gelöst
das soll jetzt nicht mehr passieren
james webb weltraumteleskop funktioniert
nicht richtig staat erneut verschoben da
gibt es mehr über die probleme mit dem
teleskop das ist wirklich ein krimi also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran